thanks a lot indeed my name is Mattia
I'm a little scientist at Buckman and
today I would like to tell you about the
benefit of doing external validation
that's using data set which is different
the one you use for the model
development development coming from a
different domain and yeah we work with
medical data so for us domain different
domain normally means a different
Hospital and if you were in the talk in
the other room right before lunch then
probably some of the things that were
discussed there you will recognize them
in my talk I'd like to give you a little
bit of study of the Libertyville context
so you already have your model that has
been trained and you're relatively
satisfied with the performance and then
you want to move to the next phase which
involves implementation or probably
selling the model so to a different
client and your client and all those
scenarios involve using them basel to a
data set that is different than the one
that you've been used for the
development and there's no guarantee
that the very nice performance that you
had also applied to the new data set so
I didn't want to be super precise by
giving numbers yet but this is the
situation that we will have good
performance if you just use your own
development at the site both for
training and tested but and then if you
want to test it on the new one the
performance will likely drop and well
what we what we like to address in this
talk is why this happened and which are
the techniques that can be used to to
solve this they fall broadly under the
common umbrella name of domain
adaptation the goal is of course to get
back over here with a good performance
and in that case if you manage to do
that then domain repetition will have
until you a new version of your model
which is at the same time more flexible
but also more accurate and for us
accurate means safer for patients the
other very nice benefit of doing
external validation is is this the fact
that healthcare is quickly warming up to
the concept of machine learning and
there's a lot of more scientific paper
that has been popped the
are published deep day by day trying to
use machine learning to solve clinically
relevant questions however there's still
quite some challenging to have those
models leave the pages of a scientific
journal and actually been implemented in
practice as of this summer only 46 of
those machine learning algorithms like
actually been fda-approved and well
there are many reasons for this one of
them is that those models are not
flexible enough they cannot be
transferred so the the process that I've
mentioned before of external validation
if you try to start to consider it as a
standard and common step in the process
of model development that will bridge
the gap between development and and
actual implementation so I decided to
split my presentation in three sections
and the first one I'm going to tell a
little bit about Buckman and especially
one of the models that we've been
developing developing called practicum
very critical and that will be our use
case for the rest of representation in
the second part I'm going to dig in a
little bit deeper in what I mean by the
main application and present some of the
techniques that we experimented with and
then in the last part I'm going to show
you how this technique will benefit the
case of magma critical so yeah let's
start in pac-man we combine machine
learning with the medical spirit
expertise to provide tools algorithms
that can support physicians and doctors
in their day-to-day decisions our goals
are to have it so that patients only
receive treatment that actually improve
their quality of life that every doctor
can learn from the decision that the
other colleagues make and then at the
end of the day the already reduced
budget the voltage to healthcare is
actually suspended more efficiently we
have different projects going on right
now in different areas of healthcare
going from oncology to triage to primary
care today today I'm going to tell you
something about the intensive care unit
of a hospital the patient that are
admitting to the ICU are in a very
critical state and
it's the job of the intensivist of the
doctor there to stabilize the patient so
that he or she can be discharged to a
lower level word and the problem is that
5% fibers 5 percent of those discharged
patients they then die or readmit into
the intensive care within 7 days of the
discharge this of occurred of course
negative outcome that could arguably be
prevented if you delay a little bit the
moment of the of the discharge and
that's what what Padma critical wants to
do we want to use all the data gathered
from patients during their stay in the
intensive care unit to predict what's
the probability for that patients to
either come back or die if you were to
discharge that patient right now
and just for simplicity from now I'm
just going to say probability of
readmission but what I really mean is
either very mission or death and then we
provide this probability this prediction
probability to the doctor so that he or
she can take that into account on
whether to confirm or not the decision
to discharge the patient this is a
project that started two years ago with
the Amsterdam USA they provide us 14,000
ICU admission with historical data from
2004 until 2017 this is a list of all
the signals that we are including so not
just patient demographic like age and
sex but basically everything that is
measured during the the intensive care
at the stay in the intensive care so
vital signs like heart rate respiratory
rate blood pressure clinical survey
shows like the level of consciousness
all the lab results that are taken all
the procedures that are performed like
intubations or renal replacement Theory
therapy of course there's a lot of stuff
as you can see and you should take into
account the fact that some of the
machines that are always connected to
the patient like the bed monitor they
measure and gather data with a frequency
that can be as high as 3 times per
minute so you end up with a lodge with a
with a very large amount of data there
must be some step of feature engineering
and the way that we do it is like this
imagine this is the
evolution of heart rate measurement for
a patient we be in it with define time
windows of 24 hours and within one of
this window we compute seven feature
aggregates the min within one day the
standard deviation first and last
measurement minimum Max and then how
many times this thing has been measured
and we do this for the first 24 hours
assuming that this is a good description
of the states of the patient when he
arrives on the intensive care the same
for the last 24 hours and then over the
whole admission and this is the are the
feature that on which we build our model
on which at the end performs quite well
we have an a you see of 0.8 among the
highest form one of the highest among
the people agree rooms that I find in
the literature with a similar function
to predicting readmission so then we
were very happy with this and want you
to move forwards that's when we
encountered this problem of an external
validation we actually did this exercise
twice with two different new data set
I'm gonna call them the target dataset
while the pakmar critical the one used
for the development is going to be
called the source data set so the first
validation is actually done on the same
hospital but II got it it accounts for
the admissions after 2017 2017 they
starting to implement a new returning
patient data system called epoch so this
first target data set will include only
the admission around two thousand three
thousand ambitions after they knew that
the new system has been launched and
changing the internal patient system in
the hospital is it's quite a change so
you could you can really think of it as
a completely different hospital and then
the second well if you do that
moderation mention if you only blindly
apply part more critical to the new data
set without doing any
retraining or any routes Univ of any
sort then your performance go down to
0.76 the second validation will be done
to with data form a completely different
Hospital this is 13,000 ICU admissions
coming from the
it's a bit twisted hospital in Tilburg
and well if you do that if you apply
Padma critical to then you dataset the
drop is different more significant you
go down to zero point 69 so why is this
what's going on well the first thing
that we did is not really anything
particularly fancy or any statistical
trick is more something we have to do
with the common practice in machine
learning we basically just took for each
of the signals that we measured we took
all the measurement I was gathered for
one specific hospitals and plot their
distribution and overlay that with the
same distribution for the other hospital
for the new hospital to see if there's
any discrepancy in in dose distribution
and it's a very cool method to a very
simple method to support simple mistakes
and imprecisions things like the fact
that the same feature the same signal is
measured with different units in the two
hospitals or we also realized that we
had to align our categorical features
some of these things that were in this
last before they are registered as a
categories of strings for example the
quality of the cough but the
possibilities of these features they can
be just two in one hospital good or bad
or seven or eight in another hospital
so when then you took this and then we
fight them and transform them into
binaries there is no alignment anymore
of those of those features you something
that you should do as you can as I said
this is very simple to be honest before
which we're done this even at the very
beginning of the project and not not
after I've been noticing the drop in the
performance but with so many features to
handle it's a maybe it's not a surprise
that some of these things can slip
through the cracks but it was also very
interesting to start discussion with our
with our collaborators noticing that
indeed there are some things that are
still different even after this sanity
checks let's say for example we notice
in there is a very there's a very big
difference in how many times the two
hospitals measure lab results and this
was quite worrying with us for us
because
how many times you perform a specific
lab test is one of our most important
features and noticing that is very
different between I to hospital was I
said worrying but then we realized that
indeed one of the two hospital had daily
routinely batteries of tests they do
just every day while the other one they
the the doctor has actually has actually
to order the different lab results and
that can explain the difference all of
this one of these things that has to do
with a different distribution in your
features
it's called covariant shift it it can
come from a different patient population
or different structure practices in the
offices like in the in the hospital like
when I just mention about the lab
results it basically means that while
you're training on your source model the
source doesn't see as many example they
are similar to the one in the in the
target model so then when you test it on
the target it will you're bound to see
some to make some errors and this is
indeed something that affects also our
case and to convince yourself of that
you just have to notice that at the
answer a you um say fifty five percent
of those admissions are cardio patients
what the number is less than ten percent
and it is answer there is certainly a
different patient population how can you
solve it you can do importance waiting
meeting then while you're training on
the source you give more weight to the
examples that are more similar between
source and target there is one
additional thing that can go wrong
called concept zip shift and in this
case what changes is not the
distribution of the features but the
relationship between the feature and the
outcome that's actually something that's
the thing that you want to model so
imagine that you train your model on
that on the target set you managed to
reproduce one specific dependence then
you move to another hospital have a
different one again you're bound to make
some mistakes on the on the target set
and well an example of this of this
phenomenon is what I told you before
about the number of lab results we were
not surprised to
notice that this was one of our most
important features because if you think
of it a doctor order a lab result when
he or she thinks that the patient has
something wrong so it's it's reasonable
to see that them number is related to
the outcome but of course this is only
true if those lab results are not done
routinely every day then that relation
with the outcome is completely disrupted
by taking away the component of the
actual decision of the doctor and
another example is what you see here the
two distribution shows the distribution
of one of our feature doesn't matter
what it is in in one word to hospital in
green and the other one in orange the
fact that the two distribution are
different that's the covariance shift in
the previous slide but here you also see
how the outcome depends how the outcome
changes as you move as a function of
those features and again you see a the
two lines are clearly different so a
manifestation of the of the constant
shift how can we solve it there are
different possibilities the first one
well you just put a little together you
train on both train on both target and
source this indeed will probably lead
you to a big improvement in the AUC
there is one problem and that's to do
more with the legal side of things
because in order to have that you need
the two date set to be actually present
in the same point in the same place and
accessible by the same user and normally
hospitals do not really like to to share
data we for a moment when you're allowed
to do this so alternatively what you can
do is use sequential model where you
train your normal model only on the
source which is your normal loss
function and then you export the
knowledge gathered by the on the on the
source to the to the target by training
a do a new different in separate model
add in an additional term here when
there is a regular regularization term
that penalizes any difference in the
coefficients between target and test so
in this case the two dates and do not
have to be present in the same in the
same place your training two different
model and you
transferring the knowledge of the model
encoded in the coefficient so this is
okay the one of the problems our weather
however is that in this specific flavor
of sequential model you can only do it
in four form for a linear model if you
want something that can also you can
only be also be applied by for for
nonlinear models then you can do
something like this again a sequential
model but now you train you train your
model on the target and then transfer
that information to the source by
including as a feature their predictive
probability of the target model again
the idea is more as the same as in the
previous slide you're trying to model
deviation from the from the source data
set but and you're not do you not
require to to to put the data together
another alternative the last one that
I'm going to mention today are your
article model so in this case we have a
different set of coefficients for each
domain they are written like that so
there is a part that is common and then
one that is more domain-specific and
then you train on everything both target
and source together each one with their
own set of regularization terms and the
benefit there are a lot of benefit for
these these class of models one is that
you can you can not just include two
domains but I have a whole hierarchy of
domains the other one that this is very
easy to encode things like the concept
shift because now every heavy signal
that we measure will have its own set of
coefficients that are domain dependent
so the same features can have different
effects in different domain in different
hospitals and another another benefit is
that you can encode it in fact you can
encode some kind of in medical knowledge
by putting some priors on the
regularization terms however as in the
very first solution that I told you now
you are trading on source and target
together so there's that
yeah let's see what works best at least
in the case of Padma critical so this
first slide show you the results of the
first validation that we did so the one
before 2017 and after 2017 we were
starting for him around a 0.76 that's
the first column on the left if you
forget everything I just told you about
the main repetition and just train a
model on the target data set then
doesn't that the second column it
doesn't get you much further just just a
small improvement but then if you do
implement the technique that we
discussed right now you see that you can
get to very high values is similar to
what we had and at the very first first
slides and the second validation the one
between um sternum say and a tea set so
in this case we were starting even lower
around 0.7 in this case if I forget
about the main adaptation and just train
a model only on it is that data then I
do see a big jump I get already as up at
0.74 however well this model will have
the same problem that Padma critical had
at the beginning it's not transferable
it will only be you can only apply this
to the patient intercept on the other
hand you should prefer solutions that
involve the main a petition like the one
that are presented here because it makes
me model more flexible and also you gain
little bit more of of accuracy by the
way I'm not showing you the other two
bars there because those are the the
technique the algorithms that require to
train on both target and source and
we're not allowed to do that as I said
so I was a bit surprised when I saw
these results especially because they
seem so different in the two exercises
that we that we did especially in the
second column the effect that the
difference you can see by training only
a model on the target and then I
suspected that that was due to the fact
that the two the two data set are so
different in size the one the one here
the target only has well less than three
under new admissions the ones after 2017
well in this case is
13,000 admissions or the same size of
the of the source data set and so to
confirm this hypothesis what I did was
check the evolution of the performance
over as the as the size of the of the
target set increases and that's the
result so on the on the x axis you see
the the number of examples in the target
increasing more and more
and on the y the performance the a you
see the orange line is the model train
only on the target that has you increase
the number of x servation slowly climbs
up but if you do domain repetition then
you see that you already have a you know
the Vantage already from the very
beginning still with only 1000
admissions events you already have a
very high level of performance of a UC
so i stopped at three around two hundred
and twenty eight hundred which is where
we are within the first case that we
consider but if I extend the axis then
the model develop only on the target
will have still kept rising until
reaching the performance of the
techniques with the magnification and
that's how we are with the second
validation humston
um say an dataset so that's the reason
why in this case the the demand a
petition they are not adding as much as
they was do as they were doing before
which to me suggests that all these
techniques they are certainly more
viable he if the target dataset is
smaller and that's pretty much it I want
to summarize my my conclusions well the
first and most important fact is that
indeed to my reputation we think it's an
important tool to make your model more
flexible and safer for us it's certainly
benefited the pack more critical now is
it can be applied to a larger set of
patients and making it also ready to
actually be more read more closer to be
implemented in in practice these
techniques they they certainly work they
Obama more beneficial in if you're if
you want to use a targeted strategies
that is more
and among the all the ones that we will
be considered today the one that rely on
sharing the data among hospitals they
are they add more value than the other
one so if you can do it then you should
certainly go for those but even if you
cannot do that then things like like
sequential models are certainly still of
certainly beneficial yeah Thanks so you
have the attention
[Applause]